comme bonjour vous êtes né à quimper
vous vivez actuellement la forêt
fouesnant
vous avez été équipiers de patrick
tabarly en 1981 dans la course autour du
monde
puis celui de patrick morvan entre
autres lors du premier record de
l'atlantique obtenu par battu par jet
services
et puis l'année dernière vous avez
remporté le challenge international de
formule 40 cette année vous êtes le
premier champion du monde de cette
spécialité à la première rejoindra
peut-être rappeler un peu ce que sont
les formules 40 je crois qu'en fait
cette catégorie a été créée il ya
environ quatre ans et c'était pour
permettre à des gens qui ne pouvaient
pas avoir des budgets de sponsoring
absolument démesuré de pouvoir quand
même participé à la compétition de voile
ont eu 40 sont des multicoques de 12
mètres 12 mètres de long et donc qu'ils
ont
qui ont pour but de
je donc de courir sont des bateaux qui
sont qui se rapproche plus du formule 1
que de que d'un bateau trace aussi
annick qui est lui plus plus relié je
dirai au paris dakar où ce genre de
course donc ce sont des courses qui se
déroulent sur des circuits en une heure
et demie de temps donc kiss kiss qui
permet au public de venir voir les
bateaux et de créer une animation autour
de ça ce sera absolument pas des bateaux
qui paie par exemple sociale non pas du
tout ce sont les bateaux très pointue
avec des techniques des techniques
nouvelles très développé non ce qui fait
qu'on va toujours de plus en plus loin
pour aller de plus en plus vite et ça
nous amène à avoir des bateaux vraiment
pointu et puis très intéressant très
intéressant dans le domaine aussi de du
développement des des multicoques en
général et tout ce développement
s'appliqueront sûrement un jour
justement à la plaisance vous avez connu
vous quand même l'ivresse de ces grande
transocéanique est-ce que vous avez
laissé complètement tombé ce type de
course maintenant pour participer donc
la cl course de formule 1 de la mer
comme en pays non j'ai pas j'ai pas
complètement laissé tomber mais pour le
moment bon bah je suis dans une période
où je fais du forme 40 parce que c'est
une
c'est une formule très structurée avec
j'irai des budgets tout à fait
raisonnable donc qu'on a on a plus de
facilité à s'organiser au niveau d'un
formule 40 15
un qu'un plus gros bateau et je dirais
que c'est pour nous aussi très
intéressant puisque la compétitivité de
ces bateaux là est très importante donc
en tant que coureur être
sur une ligne de départ avec c'est très
pointu
c'est intéressant alors ça a été donc
créé en france il ya quatre ans à peu
près c'est une formule êtes champion du
monde donc ça veut dire que c'est une
formule qui s'internationalise
c'est ça c'est à dire que pour l'année
prochaine on fait un championnat
d'europe qui va se dérouler sur sur sept
épreuves dont une épreuve hier à
douarnenez le du 13 au 16 juillet
ensuite on aura un championnat du monde
donc sur une sur dix jours qui se
déroulera à torben en italie en
parallèle il ya un circuit américain qui
va être créée et un circuit spécifique
ce qui fait qu'on internationalisme la
formule 40 et nous on va justement pas
avec toute l'équipe de de cdk de céder
la compétition et biscuits cantereau on
part avec le bateau hawaï pour disputer
une épreuve qui se déroulera du 5 au 15
janvier
alors je l ai dit tout à l'heure dans le
sommaire jean le cam vous faites partie
de l'équipe finistérienne de voile qui
comporte plusieurs plusieurs grands noms
a entre autres les deux médaillés
olympiques aussi futée citer philippe
poupon est ce que c'est important de
faire partie maintenant d'une équipe qui
est soutenu en fait par tout un
département
moi je crois que cette année on a eu
beaucoup de résultats donc avec les deux
médailles d'or
olympiques qu'on a eu autrement planche
à voile de nombreux de nombreux succès
donc la région je dirai tout le
finistère en ce moment commence à
s'apercevoir que ben qu'on est là et
puis quand on gagne non seulement en
bretagne en finistère mais dans le monde
entier donc c'est aussi l'image du
finistère bien sûr qu'on véhicule à
travers tous ces résultats et puis ces
bateaux je pense qu'il ya important
qu'aujourd'hui vont à en prenne
conscience de ça et que en bretagne bon
on a quand même plus de 1000 km de côtes
donc c'est vraiment un endroit qu'il
faut qu'il faut développer dans le sens
maritime est donc à nouveau à cette
occasion là ce soir
le conseil général du finistère
j'accueille accueille tous les tous les
champions à 18 heures donc sous la
présidence de charles milhaud sec mais
alors ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
vous êtes très vite parce qu'il nous
reste peu de temps le parrain de
l'équipe finistérienne d'optimiste qui
se débrouille pas mal du tout je crois
aussi là on l'avait prêté à l'as on
optimiste
là je crois que les gars ils sont ils
sont bien après ils vont ils ont en plus
un entraînement très assidu il faut les
voir naviguer puisqu'ils sont vraiment
bons d jerry font tous jeunes et ils
connaissent déjà tous deux les règles
ils réclament ils connaissent les
réclamations ils connaissent et
connaissent vraiment tout un tout ce
qu'il faut connaître pour courir ça
c'est toute une préparation c'est ce
qu'il faut développer dans le finistère
merci jean d'être venu nous parler de la
formule 40 et puis de cette équipe
finistérienne de voile avec laquelle je
crois qu'il va falloir compter très très
sérieusement dans les mois qui viennent
oui c'est ça je bouge trop sur ma chaise
on précisé c'est insupportable en plus
elle grâce bon je vais essayer de me
calmer
merci
[Musique]